Norway chess tournament has started in
forests a small town in the stefano
region in norway the chest fever is in
full swing again with live coverage of
the tournament on Norway's popular
sports channel TV two commentators hunts
all of lalamon grandmas to see Menaka
Stein are almost as famous as Magnus
Carlsen the world champion did not
manage to win the first two editions and
it will be difficult to win the third he
is in a shocking last place of her two
rounds Carlsen lost to visit him to pile
up on time as he didn't know the time
control and the next day he was
outplayed by Fabiana Caruana
I got a good position from the opening
and I mean after that I just I played
well and I think it was a good game I
don't think I made any mistakes or maybe
some slight inaccuracies but nothing to
to jeopardize the win um and I just just
outplayed him from some point and what
about him I guess he made too many
inaccuracies I I don't think he played
badly but um he was let down by by his
preparation I he probably looked at this
but not very deeply he thought that
Bishop ephod would come as a surprise
but but I knew about it and and he just
did another position as well as I did
after that I mean new it's a pretty big
advantage when you know how good your
position is you know what the computer
is recommending or we've analysed
something compared to someone who's just
playing over the board even though at
some point I went out but but I knew the
main ideas and can do I mean it wasn't a
big problem finding investments do you
think he's an yeah disastrous loss
yesterday played a role in today's game
I really don't know it's impossible for
an outsider to to say what was what's
going on is in his mind um I didn't
think it would um and I don't know if it
did I mean it's it's clear he had other
problems besides I mean in this game he
had problems from the start of the game
so maybe it was just a typical position
from opening for him and maybe it didn't
have anything to do with the game
yesterday and about this time control
were you actually aware of of the track
control at this tournament in
yesterday's round no the orbiter said it
before the game but I didn't hear it
clearly but to be honest at some point
if if I have a feeling that I'll be in
time trouble I just go and ask the
arbiter to make sure it often happens is
during tournaments um but yesterday my
game was pretty didn't even go to time
control and I wasn't in time pressure I
was just a bit surprised because I mean
Magnus went to move 40 and the time is
automatically added and so he probably
should realize that the time is
automatically added and it wasn't
automatic automatic Lee I didn't move 60
so there was no I mean there was no
increment I mean no not her time control
in the third round Carlsen will face
giri whom he has never beaten yet let's
go back one more time to the opening
press conference he is one of the if you
look at my scores with other players
she's one of the easiest opponents for
me so that's not the problem but all the
others are the others are going to be
tough yes yes he still has the the
bragging rights in our image individual
encounters so good friend let's see what
the third round will bring